it says here in training for general
ship it seems that intellectual ability
has not always counted for very much
even hague the educated soldier became
commander-in-chief of the british army
in the first world war despite a poor
academic record
this dowerlin scott this tower lowland
scott described by duff cooper as the
dunce of the family and by lord george
as utterly stupid
so you are getting some dumb people here
um fast forward a little certainly a
brilliant performance in military
schools is no guarantee of subsequent
ability general kali whose secession of
defeats culminated in 1881 in his own
demise at mujaba hill
had the distinction of passing out of
staff college with the highest
marks on record
the irrelevance of early scholarship to
subsequent general ship also finds
support in napoleon and wellington both
of whom achieved very low grades at
school and in more recent times the
early academic brilliance of lieutenant
general percival evidently availed him
little at singapore so he's given all
these other examples right you got
percival who led that total disaster in
singapore
who was
uh academically brilliant
napoleon and wellington who were great
generals who were junk at school and
another guy general cauley who is a
disaster on the battlefield and yet had
the highest marks on record
so
the statement is like hey
you could be really smart and do well
you could be really smart and do
horrible you could be moderately smart
and do well you could be moderately
smart and do horrible so i think the
statement here is like well
it's not
intellect is only part of it
right intellect is only part of it
what about um fighter pilots
i mean look so in the seal teams for a
while they were recruiting these really
really smart ivy league you know harvard
yale there was all this whole crew of
officers that were coming in they were
clearly
highly intellectual smart people
and they stopped recruiting those people
so heavily and the reason they stopped
recruiting those people so heavily was
two reasons one was they would do their
one platoon or two platoons and get out
and go to business school or whatever
and two was they weren't that good yeah
there was no there was no correlation
to someone that was really smart to
someone that was a really good leader on
the battlefield yeah i i think it's the
same i really do i i don't think
i don't think the personality profile
you know or even just the motivational
profile of of a lot of people in the
military is all that different certainly
when i think about seals and pilots and
as often as you and i kind of contrast
those two types of people there's a ton
of similarity there and you know the
different services in aviation have
different
sets of of requirements and you know i
think
the marine corps has the
the lowest i guess standard of academic
excellence uh in terms like what you
studied and how well you did i mean the
old joke in the marine corps was you
know if you got a 2.0 and underwater
basket weaving you could be a pilot
you know is the joke and you know what
they were saying really was hey
you know
we don't really care what you studied
now you gotta have a college degree and
i think that does demonstrate some
willingness and ability
and i'm not sure which is more important
to get through a long-term project that
hey i'm going to dedicate four years to
getting this degree that demonstrates
hey you've got some planning you've got
some interest you've got some intellect
something that's going to reveal
that you're you are have something
that's going to be hard to do you're
going gonna be willing to do that
you're getting a 4.0 you know in uh you
know
aerodynamics versus a 2.0 in poli-sci we
don't really care yeah that was kind of
the marine corps general approach a
little bit different for the other
services but i was kind of laughing and
kind of
thinking about this thing from a larger
standpoint of these great military
leaders that
maybe didn't have the best records
academically
i mean the two thoughts that i had is
the academics in the military aren't
that hard they're not that hard you know
what i mean like you don't need to be a
genius to get perfect scores on your
tests
um
and i think the ones that don't do that
well academically that are that still
really do well there's probably a piece
in there they're thinking like
this is dumb this is a waste of my time
what's the what's the minimum grade
requirement yeah cool i'm going to get
that and there that actually reveals
some level of intelligence i'm not going
to waste my time and all this stuff that
i don't really want to be doing
but i'm not going to fail either so for
for you to sort of explain
there's some really good leaders that
didn't do so hot and then there's some
guys that just were absolutely brilliant
on paper that were terrible that is not
a stretch for me
at all to picture that in in aviation or
anywhere in the middle term like i think
i know who those guys are
yeah and really
in anything anything there's no there
i'm trying to think of a job
where the full
where where the the primary thing is
only intelligence
only intelligence i'm sure there's some
laboratory somewhere or some computer
programming thing where basically the
smartest person is the person that we
want in that job yeah
but as soon as that person is in charge
of people anyone else totally or in
certain as soon as there's some level of
creativity or problem solving because
there's
you just you what you want is a person
that
the composite has a bunch of different
skills i mean you would think for being
a pilot
uh
there's got to be you know that that
like the spatial like when i took the
officer candidate
test and you've got to do the spatial
recognition where how far away is this
or is this aircraft or is this bird
coming to you or going away from you got
to tell from looking at it
hey obviously someone could be really
really smart and suck at that test right
not to mention eyesight not to mention
reaction time like all those different
things and then it's the same thing with
leadership
you can have someone that's super
articulate
there's there's really articulate people
that aren't really that smart
i mean i served with some people like
that they're really articulate they can
put a word word together what do people
call them when eel you know that's a
skill set that like a salesperson
there's really good sales people they're
not the smartest people in the world but
they're incredible at their incredible
conversationalists yeah right but you
wouldn't want to put them into a
situation where they've got to stand up
and talk in front of people if they
don't have that skill so just because
someone is smart that's only like one
quarter of the
of the of the math we got to do here
totally and when you're thinking about
it from a leadership standpoint
and
the recognition that that leadership
requires a whole bunch of different
things
not just being smart and taking a test
or being good at communicating it's
the recognition that it requires so many
different things none of these these
profiles that he just revealed are a big
shock to me i'm like yep yep yep those
all make sense seals pilots everywhere
in between and yeah
in aviation is there a couple things
that might incline you down that path
like if you can naturally get a sense if
they show you a diagram of an airplane
descending turning and slow and then you
have to match it up that some people's
brains may be oh i can't i can't see
that as well as somebody else yeah i
could see that and that's gonna account
for a small part of it that might be
good to know
but that by itself is
it's gonna
it's gonna have almost no influence in
the long-term success of this person in
his career in the military that i could
identify relatively early on of what the
spatial orientation of an airplane was
in relation to the ground do you want
that yeah that's a good idea i don't
want someone who who gets confused you
don't want someone that's totally lost
right i mean even on that test you all
you have to do is pass it right oh
that's all you have to do and then you
know if you and i were in the same thing
and i was a little bit worse i would
study it more i figured out more or i
just after whatever two months of
looking at that stuff we're the same yes
because i figured out how to figure it
out yeah
that's right check